你不用管背后是因为什么原因，
是因为他放不下身段也好，
是因为他觉得这是一种策略也好，
他说破天了，
说什么借口，
我告诉你，
你感受不到他在热烈的爱着你，
他就是没有那么喜欢你，
我现在也到了一个适婚的年纪了，
然后这三位男生呢，
他们都是独生子，
A的话他这个工作是一位男老师，
然后A的这个个人方面就是外形比较好，
就一米八五，
平时也爱健身，
也非常的会穿搭，
你也很顾家，
也会做饭，
花钱也很大方，
和我相处这个过程中也非常的照顾我，
比如说我跟他出去吃饭，
我从来没有夹过菜，
生活中也很关心我，
就会观察你缺什么东西，
比如说夏天会给你买个夏凉被，
买点鞋子，
买点什么，
也很有耐心，
比如说会带你去游泳，
教你去打球，
就整个人让你挺舒服的，
他在寒暑假的方面也能帮你带个娃之类的，
以后他的这个为人处事可能会稍微差一点，
就是性格稍微有点估僻，
抖音会发一些东西，
他发的那些东西我都说实话我有点看不上，
就觉得他发这些东西很低俗，
我总感觉我俩没有那种深入的精神交流，
就除了这就是外表，
我很喜欢，
但是我又又觉得他这个性格有点孤僻，
就不受朋友的喜欢，
很多想法也有点跟不上时代。
另一个就是他这个人比较保守，
就是比如说我想买新房，
他们家只能买新房，
背房贷，
他。
对，
最后还是选择装修老房子，
我就觉得我性格也内向，
他也内向，
就是未来就是怎么过呢，
找个会来事儿的可能会轻松很多，
但他个人方面，
第二个就是他家庭方面，
他父母本来都有正式工作，
但是听说他的父亲可能上个世纪那时候可能不是很正规的时候，
参加过这种打人斗殴，
这工作就没了，
他家里面就说他父亲是被冤枉的，
而且没有案底，
要不然他也正式工作，
他也考不进来，
然后我就觉得他爸妈还有他的性格都不太受人喜欢，
而且他父亲就是说从这个事情以后一直没有上班，
就是感觉有点游手好闲，
这是A的一个情况，
A是本科，
B的情况，
就是说B是国企的，
B和C都是研究生，
B跟A完全是相反的，
干嘛，
就是说他在身高外貌上没有优势，
但是他这个性格就非常的开朗，
非常的热爱生活，
非常的有梗，
就是永远笑嘻嘻的，
很会来事儿，
就是属于那种几句话就可以把女生哄开心的，
你和他出去玩呢，
你永远都很开心，
就春夏秋冬带你去户外玩就很浪漫，
你也能跟他聊得来。
其实我刚开始对B的外表不是很喜欢，
但是跟她在一块儿久了，
觉得跟他在一块很开心，
就很有生命力，
就也挺崇拜他的，
因为你不管去哪里玩，
他都能给你讲很多的人文知识啊，
历史知识，
包括就是他工作里的一些事，
你就觉得这个人很厉害，
就是你很崇拜他，
但是这也是他的一个缺点，
就因为他很会哄女生开心嘛，
所以他虽然。
在条件很一般，
但是也会有很多女生在他周边，
就是我俩没在一起的时候，
我就会发现他也有同事和其他女生在聊，
而且差点有实质性的行为，
我跟他去对峙过这个事情，
他说是因为当时就是大家都是单身，
我跟他也没有在一起，
他感觉他要被我拒绝了，
所以他觉得他联系其他女生也是应该的。
后来被我发现之后，
他也很真诚的在忏悔这个事情，
就是把所有人都删了，
以后再也不会做这种事情，
然后想谈一个一心一意的其他你不用担心我的条件，
因为我条件肯定是比这三个都要强的，
所以我才会来连麦。
他的缺点可能就是说是他父母的话没有工作，
就是相对于A和C的话，
他父母没有工作，
但是有存款，
存款大概在150左右，
就房子和车子这方面都不用担心，
都是新房新车，
但是他父母还有六七年才能去领上那个灵活退休，
每个月大概就只有1000多的退休工，
就相对于A和C，
他父母这方面肯定是相对来说弱势的，
并且他父亲这方面就是说有肠癌，
但是发现比较早，
就已经手术过了，
生存期也很长，
定期复查就可以。
C的话就是他是条件最好的，
不管他自己的工作，
还有他父母，
他自己也是保持父母都是国企退休车了，
房子是全款，
就我们聊天也能聊得来，
但是总感觉大家没有产生情愫，
我俩认识一个月的时候，
他就跟我表白了，
也有送金子，
但是我就。
呃，
车管家这个东西太贵重了，
我也觉得，
就是我俩聊了一个月没有什么感觉，
就是我们在接触一下，
但是到现在我们接触了2个月了，
就是也没有确定关系，
每天都是聊微信，
从来没有打过电话，
我就觉得这个从来没有打过电话很离谱，
因为大家认识两个月了嘛，
然后昨天我就把金子还给他了，
我跟他说，
我说我们要是没有意思，
就不要互相耽搁对方了，
然后他跟我说是因为他怕太主动了会失去主动性，
就好几次他说他想给我打电话，
但怕我烦他，
所以他也有点放不下身段，
如果他觉得他不喜欢我，
为什么还要跟我聊天，
找我吃饭呢？
但是我总觉得他更倾向于说我们两个的条件非诚合适，
就我觉得我们两个没有冲动，
你去看条件，
当然是C最好，
我总觉得人生呢，
这一辈子难道就为了条件去选择C吗？
就是三个人的情况你都说过吗？
A有，
A是前任，
他的这个性格什么的我不是很喜欢，
因为就觉得你如果连这个人，
你就没有内心的发自内心去尊尊重他，
认可他，
可能你们就是会有看不起他的想法，
可能没有办法和我在一起，
然后A就直接pass掉了，
你都对过他了，
你对他还是有点挑三拣四的，
就表示感觉也一般，
但是我现在就很倾向于A，
就是说他是外貌，
然后什么最好的，
有时候在还会想，
哦，
我跟你讲啊，
就是这玩意跟外貌不挂钩，
身高也不挂钩，
那个带一点点，
这个我不太擅长的领域，
甚至跟。
气味什么的是挂钩的，
他身体里面释放出一种气味，
而这个气味正好是在你那个区域当中，
你闻着很舒服的，
这都会有挂钩，
跟他长得帅，
身高啊什么的就不挂钩，
你既然A你已经跟他有过亲密的关系了，
但是A依然是没有走进你的心理，
对吧？
没有真正的走进你的心理，
那就pass掉了，
B的话就是说你跟他在一起真的很快了，
那你说是这个生理性喜欢的话，
好像就像王菲姐说的，
你你喜欢一个人会觉得他身上有很好闻的味道，
但是我总觉得病须上会有一股不好闻的味道，
但是你跟他在一起就觉得很开心。
我这个观点可能会被骂，
保证身体健康，
没有传染性疾病，
各方面都没有什么的情况下，
试一下做好避孕措施，
但是我就觉得应该没什么问题吧，
就是闭合，
所以因为他们平时也会去胃必和，
什么胃病，
就要跟他身体健不健康，
跟他荷尔蒙分泌强不强都不直接挂钩，
包和这个方面的，
这个我们可以从其他方面再聊一下B和C嘛，
好，
你再说一下B和C，
咱们已经说了优点啊，
现在说一点你最不能容忍的点是哪些？
不，
我总担心B会出，
因为他跟你聊的很开心，
就身边也会有其他的女生，
他把每个人都能哄开心，
这么跟你说吧，
B和C他们的出轨概率相差不大，
但是我就总觉得B是面有很多的女。
生，
但是目前C身边就是他不会因为这种性格的原因，
所以B身边真的有很多女生，
然后B和C他俩的区别，
其实就是说C的条件最好，
因为我家里人都在劝我选CC的话有点就是觉得我条件也合适，
这种感觉并不是说两个人有什么感情，
虽然他也跟我解释了，
他说是其实他对我有感情的，
只是因为他觉得放不下身段什么的，
跟你讲一个事儿啊，
这事儿很扎心，
你感受不到他喜欢你，
他就是不咋喜欢你，
你不用管背后是因为什么原因，
是因为他放不下身段也好，
是因为他觉得这是一种策略也好，
他说破天了，
说什么借口，
我告诉你，
你感受不到他在热烈的爱着你，
他就是没有那么喜欢你，
所有人都在劝我去想C，
就说C条件好，
其实我觉得还是回到我自己身上啊，
如果我各方面条件也很好，
我要先想明白了，
我想要的东西是什么，
我能否接受一个，
他也不是这么爱我，
甚至将来有一天他就算跟外面的女人了，
我也不会伤心到吃不下饭。
我想要的就是一种稳定的合伙关系，
家庭关系，
相敬如宾，
我们可以一起共同去投资一个项目，
去生一个孩子，
陪伴孩子的成长呢？
还是说我想要一个那种啊，
被一个人牵动着情绪啊，
能够他哄我，
我就很开心。
呃，
情绪上会有波动的，
这样一个两性关系，
所以这事儿一定要从从你自己身上出发，
你先想好了你想要什么，
我以前找对象的时候，
就找结婚对象的时候，
我首先看中的就是他的生存能力，
他赚钱的能力，
他解决问题的能力，
他遇到挫折的能力，
其他的都是排在后面的。
我说这个话没没有说你一定要参照我的标准去做的意思，
我就是想告诉你，
女人一旦想明白了自己想要什么这个东西的话，
自己就好过。
你有认真分析过你想要什么吗？
你想要A的颜值身高，
B的情商，
C的家事，
直播家姐妹估计都会这么想的，
自己的世不差，
那么家世这个东西的话，
他就不应该成为最重要的一个因素了，
我们家的条件就是比较好的，
然后因为我们在做生意，
但是我的父亲或者说是我身边的人就会告诉我，
B为什么这么哄着我，
是因为我们家条件好，
我跟你讲啊，
姐妹啊，
千万不要陷入一种误区，
说因为我条件好，
所以我就不能找那种因为我条件好就扑上来的人。
我现在的观点是，
我条件好也是我的魅力值的之一，
条件好的女生多了，
她怎么不去哄别的条件好的呢？
现在是这样想问题的啊，
就像那个杨幂说，
如果哪个男的是冲着我的钱来，
那可太好了，
我有钱。
大概就是这个逻辑，
但我条件好本身就是跟我是一体的，
我没有必要因为这个事情去好像就设置一条门槛，
谁都不能冲着我条件好来对我好了，
不是的，
就像举个例子吧，
说我找老公，
我想找一个能挣钱的，
然后我老公说，
哎，
你的都是冲着我的钱来的，
他可能就拒绝我了，
是吧？
但我老公他可能也看得很开，
他说我有钱也是我优秀的一部分啊，
当然可以冲着我的钱来啊，
嗯，
好难想啊，
反正A肯定pass掉了，
但是B和CB是知道有C的存在的，
但是C不知道BB现在其实有点像在竞争关系，
因为我也跟他说了，
我说我觉得不能同时拖你们太久就是，
不然我自己道德上我也过不去，
我觉得既然B她也是把你当成一个选择的对象的话，
你先把利死了，
看看感觉怎么样，
行，
我再考虑一下，
好OK，
好，
就这样啊，
嗯，
拜拜，
哎呀，
这个东西我咋说呢？
因为女人的身体是骗不了人的，
你的身体喜不喜欢她，
你骗不了人，
骗不了自己，
也骗不了对方。
当然首先确保啊，
抽个血验一下有没有什么传染性疾病，
没有传染性疾病做好避孕措施。
我老跟姐妹们说啊，
谈恋爱搞对象，
不要跟三无的人去搞对象，
三无的人是什么意思呢？
他没有稳定的社会关系，
没有工作养活自己的能力，
他啥啥啥啥都没有，
你。
跟他搞对象的话，
就是拿你的命在赌，
因为你想要跟他分开的话，
对于他来说的话，
损失太大了，
他很难承接这样的损失，
但凡是他自己有一份稳定的社会关系，
有养活自己的工作，
他有好的前途，
他不会跟你要死要活的，
一般情况下是这样，
对不对？
但如果说他什么都没有的人，
他只有你，
你有一天你不想跟他过了，
他就跟你干到死了，
记得点关注。